et on retrouve donc Ludovic de Foucault
notre envoyé spécial à asaporridia en
Ukraine il y a donc eu de nombreuses
réticents ukrainiennes avant de signer
cet accord vous avez donc pu obtenir des
informations auprès de l'entourage du
président Zelenski pas auprès de
n'importe qui d'ailleurs avec le
conseiller en chef de la présidence
racontez-nous bonjour Ludovic
bonjour oui effectivement alors on est
on est de retour à Kiev et on a pu
s'entretenir avec Mireille lau-podollia
qui est le conseiller en chef du
président Zelinski comme comme vous
l'avez précisé donc on l'a rencontré à
la présidence et c'est vrai que c'est la
prudence qui qui règne qui qui domine et
d'ailleurs
Mireille oppo dolia qui nous a dit qu'on
ne pouvait pas parler d'accord au
singulier mais d'accord au pluriel que
l'Ukraine n'a signé aucun accord avec la
turc avec la Russie pardon que l'Ukraine
a signé un accord avec la Turquie et les
Nations Unies que de son côté la Russie
a signé un accord avec les Nations Unies
et la Turquie ils semblait avoir une
confusion sur les autorisations qui
seraient donnés aux Russes aux autorités
russes d'inspecter les navires qui
transportent ces céréales enfin Mirail
au podolia que a insisté sur le fait que
si des bateaux russes venaient à trop
s'approcher des portes de dessin aussi
un tir venez à toucher des ports de
dessin alors l'accord tomberait à l'eau
enfin avec Gulliver crack bon collègue
pour la chaîne anglophone nous lui avons
demandé si ces accords signés ces
signatures pouvaient signifier pour les
pays africains qui sont particulièrement
affectés par cette situation qui
pourront être livrés bientôt écoutez sa
réponse
aujourd'hui dire au pays en Afrique ils
peuvent être tranquille qu'ils peuvent
s'attendre à recevoir certaines
quantités de céréales c'est prématurés
il faut attendre un peu
on verra qu'on est transporteurs
partiront et quand ils atteindront des
autres territoriales turques par exemple
à ce moment-là on pourra dire que
l'Afrique recevra le volume des céréales
qu'elle veut
donc il faut donner du temps au temps et
voir comment le système fonctionne
je dis ça parce que aujourd'hui la
parole de la Fédération de Russie ne
vaut pas engagement
la Fédération de Russie peut violer
n'importe quel accord à n'importe quel
moment et malheureusement tout le monde
n'a pas encore compris cela en Europe
voilà donc pour cette extrait de cette
interview réalisé avec le conseiller en
chef de la présidente merci beaucoup
Ludovic pour toutes ces précisions vous
retrouve bien sûr un peu plus tard sur
nos antennes prenez soin de vous